okay i just had like the best little
nerd experience so i just stopped in at
the pet store to get more food for the
rats
important things
so i hadn't been in there for a little
bit because i tend to stock up on this
stuff last time i was in there there's a
couple of the clerks who watch doctor
who and last time i've been there they
had asked me who my favorite doctor was
i think i'd been wearing my doctor who
hoodie
and i told them capaldi and both of them
were kind of like really not like in a i
don't believe you but enough
didn't expect that and i gave the short
elevator pitch as to why i.e watching
the progression and the change in
capaldi's character from when he started
to where he ended was really magical to
me i go in there today they're both
there and individually like they weren't
there together first one comes up
to me is like
re-watch cabaldi and
now i get it
i get it and then like i'm on my way out
and the other one comes up
re-watch capaldi and yeah i get it now
you were right
love it